how's it going bro somebody though my
name is wack today we're gonna play the
Attic oh oh that was a good stretch I
was a good freakin all right let's see
what this is about father and I used to
sit out here mouthing the guests and
father I would say it out here now I was
only two and so other things were going
on in fading memory but remember one
night
Derek one day he was sucking my dick Oh
goodbye okay oh sorry and really cool
starting this game so we have been shot
yes that is already okay
sixteen years of pad and I normally met
my father and he still wait me and all I
can't stop good good good
there's a key let's go oh look at this
place it's beautiful
a friend there it's someone told me that
fine [ __ ] that's a damn fine chair
we got a Latin iron atom and sanity
potion I think about this it's slow in
the beginning this I love pity how are
you
haha what are you doing here man oh man
you so great I don't even know what I'm
doing here you there to be honest what
are you doing here with Alexander oh
yeah
Alexander he's a crazy man no you should
talk to him off I could I don't really
like ah don't judge him yes because he
wanted to kill you and stuff
anyway we got the keys at sound camera
from the Attic uh-huh okay which way
should we go Stefano this way because
it's like the only place you haven't
been so is such later cool the thing
about this modest side apparently you'll
take me forever for something scary to
happen but I don't know why I can't do
that that way let's go this way then
Stefano we're geniuses see we don't even
take damage one to jump done yeah that's
a pretty flat way off the highway
oh wait then we already been there
yeah wow so many rooms I gotta leave the
room doors open where I've been so I
don't forget yeah today PDI emetic filed
of you Thank You Stefano thank you very
much all right
it's going here spot I love the gold end
of this environment
I know fake gucci silver ladies
Gold Edition all marking and don't
closed on me buddy
Oh Connie I'll come I'll smell you and
Savannah we will go up why are you
talking like that City it's not funny
okay I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
okay let's going I'm good because I
don't want to leave it Stephano I really
don't I need you Oh buddy uh stop adding
make I'm sorry okay Oh kind way I've
been there no we haven't been here give
me go here I thought it but we can give
it a try nope can't go can't go this way
pity okay let's go here we have a key
though
it's gotta be this store okay I am
disappointed he to the third floor the
[ __ ] I don't know he do pity I am sorry
to see pissed off yeah kind of pissed
off about this the third floor how am I
supposed to know which floor I am on no
that's something right I can't use that
way eater why do you think final to find
a usual crazy tell me one of your
stories
Tammy wanna oh okay I can tell you last
summer haha I met this French girl ah
oui oui she was very beautiful in there
that's not really I come on every
freaking out don't hit my head in
everything Jesus don't okay so the only
thing we haven't tried is this door and
if this doesn't work I really really
don't feel like just walking around for
hours oh no we left so far no I need
sivanna oh man oh man final oh come on
I bet we gonna find out it crazy mofo
against it's okay
okay
can't read that if you want I'm not
gonna bother oh wow this looks good
let's go in here
nice lock good good
it's like too good oh wait I have a key
now
maybe he is the key here I have to check
cuz you never and hook and if you don't
know night
Scully what are you doing here I don't
know a well that's the fun of I saw me
like a minute ago and now I'm like this
what's all this I did it all this I
don't even have hands is he talking
about
ah it's been five hours I agree it's
been five hours oh crap
good job Scully you're pretty awesome
thank you Betty
we got Latin on about about we should
never tend to use anyways I don't know
why the game keeps keeping his Latin a
dive out of them okay boom good cool
story bro cold sorry I know I'm gonna
rip get ripped I'm gonna get today's the
big day
okay no busters I know a lot of people
who get this cuz I don't read the story
in this game but whatever I don't really
care it's like I'm thing
some instrument there something so there
was nothing in there I find that hard to
believe
well we didn't get Latin Adam Adam
there's one door we haven't and then we
go here oh well let's try it anyway
probably won't work all right
holy [ __ ] let's go to the ad I'm such a
good singer
okay so far not so bad
I mean there's doors love me some doors
step rooms haha wow this is amazing this
is amazing oh that's pretty damn [ __ ]
hello [ __ ] hi old it hello beauty I'm
pretty good
more tender boxes so I thought seriously
though we need some fun
hey Sharon have you seen Stefan huh no
is he yellow and sexy
yeah yes haven't you know come ah
sheriff's are trolling me but that's
what you get mr. sure don't be stuck on
me oh come on Ladon Adam um recipe uncle
I always wondered how you made Latin and
I'm out of him like I asked my mom
yesterday she was like I don't know what
you're talking about Latin Adam out of
my own special it's actually okay
I know that and Adam um but not lighting
that bad about about him you know oh
look at this okay yes hi older I'm a
share
okay but we'll talk later oh sure how
are y'all how much sure okay
oh look at the end in the box I have so
many pretty good in months I could
create Satan let's go actually no oh
look at this look at yes beautiful do
you think we can go here do you think
pewdie do you think do you really get
young alright we could well why do you
know PDA sometimes you are lucky
sometimes you're now oh this place looks
really scary today I would get out of
here if I were you me to Salem me too
it's so pretty dark oh good you have the
lantern why hello there Allah I am so
much as a follower who are you talking
to pretty I am Satan how y'all do ah
nice to meet you I'm Stefan hi all doing
I'm okay we're gonna leave him because
he's pretty obnoxious oh good so I was
you know and yeah okay I'm just gonna
prove to you so fun I know you're
confused enough so it's okay Thank You
Betty go along
ah sweet love me some brooms we're gonna
go in there
ah there's dead bodies there come on
I'm all dead bodies ah man I think it's
just old drunk and passed out or
something let me poke him for your pity
okay he's dead
he's definitely dead I poked a lot of
people with the sword in my life I know
if it is dead or not
hello my name's Shane okay no actually
let's go it's so annoying
okay
oh sorry Savannah that's okay penny
we just need to give the [ __ ] out of
this place
chiffon oh it's the phone oh what the
[ __ ] was that I don't know with it but I
really wanna oh what the [ __ ] is going
on with that guy he has no head
oh man oh there she said it's kind of
creepy look it's right over there yeah I
get it okay
perfect people are coming into my shop
and we have nananana Bob where's your
head that's your hair that there's your
head so funny usual crazy spider
okay
nothing in here okay let's back the [ __ ]
out back I'm backing up backing up
backing up back you know cuz my daddy
taught me again
I'm backing with Stefano here and I'm
like oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
come on don't don't do that I don't mean
Sean zombie deep come backing up backing
up backing up back oh let's not talk to
Satan right now
Savano Stefano said well I don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on I feel drunk
what the [ __ ] was that did you see I was
like simple small it's going everyday we
need to get out it's important science
huh huh what the [ __ ]
who did that oh it's doing that oh man
oh I hope we have to find out with us